I want to bring together a bunch of
financial institutions and invest
hundred billion doll in manufacturing
plants for graphine we're going to
employ 5 million people in the United
States and we're going to be exporting a
a a a building material and
superconductor which is going to be in
in major demand around the world that
will massively increase uh benefit the
US economy yeah the Department of
Defense is working with uh scientists at
Rice University to pump this stuff out
graphine I think for every $4.50 of
graphine you get a kilogram of hydrogen
fuel and so they're actually getting
they're making money to produce before
it was like it cost a dollar it cost $3
to make a kilogram of hydrogen now
you're getting $4.50 to produce a
kilogram of hydrogen it's right in front
of us so I interviewed James T today the
leading chemist one of the leading
chemists on Earth that's producing this
stuff it's an hour of us talking about
it he gets really we we scratch to the
surface and do highly highly uh
influential explanations go to my
YouTube channel and check it out it's
the first video you'll see it's James
tour this guy's phenomenal we're right
on the precipice man now we just got to
hold it together and inspire people I'm
I'm kind of at a loss of what it is that
you think graphine is going to do you
can put it in um cement in in there's a
lot of things and watch the video for if
you want to hear what does steel do well
steel is used for all kinds of stuff it
reinforces concrete and graphing does
you can put it in concrete it makes it
lighter and more three times more
durable and it's uh so we we so we we
use lithiumion batteries for our phones
they're actually starting to create uh
uh graphine polymer uh LI or lithium
graphine batteries uh graphine layer in
the battery creates a a um what's the
word lattice a unilateral charge okay so
it charges from every Point all at once
which charges the battery much more
quickly so graphine it conducts
electricity it's a superconductor okay
right so uh so whereas a cell phone
would take 50 minutes to charge in the
past it'll now take five we now have the
we actually bought a bunch of these a
year ago portable batteries when you
plug your phone in it'll charge your
phone from zero to full in 10 minutes be
uh uh or I'm sorry I'm sorry it it can
hold a full cell phone charge after only
10 or so minutes your phone whether or
not you have the graphine Polymer
batteries or or or or the gra what is it
graphine lithium I I don't know I forgot
what it's called but they're they're
they're putting them in batteries they
think that this technology in electric
car batter batteries means you'll pull
your car up to the pump at the gas
station plug in the supercharger and
you'll literally watch the charge go up
like a gas tank wow they used to they
were like how do we make this stuff
graphine for the last 20 years how do we
make a chemical vapor deposition they're
trying to deposit carbon dioxide on
copper and get it and you you get these
strips they figured out what's called
flash Jewel graphine production you you
hit it with electrical current any
Carbon on Earth you can get all these
different Plastics they used to have to
recycle them and pee pull them apart
because different Plastics recycle
differently any carbon all the plastic
together Fe human feces plants matter
any carbon and you hit it with
electricity and you turn it into
graphine and then this guy I'm actually
going to be uh uh interviewing the
inventor do we long so so but but let's
bring it back to the the the debt this
country my point is I will I will go
along with ion graphine for one reason
we need a manufacturing base we need the
American people working on raw materials
that we can use to build infrastructure
steel for a long time not just steel
there's a lot of stuff we did in the
United States we should drill baby drill
we should invade Canada I'm I'm sorry
well we should invade I'm at Alaska but
Canada yes too I mean I'm only half
kidding but no we should invade and
occupy Alaska we should not waste our
here's what I think when we go and blow
up people overseas what we are doing is
we are creating a global economy as
Hollow as a Fiat dollar we we we we
provide you nothing other than don't
screw with us and these other countries
say your offers are Hollow we only need
protection from you if the US said okay
we are going to to bolar manufacturing
develop new technologies create a very
strong robust middle class that works in
development of new technology and and
new infrastructure and new raw materials
and meta materials we occupy Alaska
using our own land to se uh Rare Earth
minerals for instance stop doing
dealings with China we would then become
that shining City on the hill and other
other nations would say we got to be
like them we got to do business with
them yeah and if we're not don't have a
global Empire you know we should be able
to do those things with without having
this Empire you mentioned the chips act
so the problem with the chips Act is
that it's basically corporate subsidies
$50 billion which is adding to the debt
the you know I think the answer isn't
subsidizing this industry um which is
something you know China does I think we
should uh you know resort to more
capitalism and deregulate and you know
give people tax incentives and to start
factories and you know they're actually
getting a lot of the Taiwanese companies
to build Factory the things that you're
gonna have to do to get to get the to
get people to start businesses like that
is I don't know I don't know the first
thing about making chips or anything but
I mean the between unions minimum wages
and the the amount of things that you
have to deregulate and pull back on it's
just astronomical so I whereas I
understand and agree with your your your
point I don't think that it's that bad
to have the government try to do things
to tax breaks or whatever to incentivize
companies to start it but they're giving
them billions of dollars check out uh
you know 50 billion that's a lot of
money I'd rather them give it to to a
company in the US than give it to Israel
to drop bombs they're giving it to a lot
a lot of it's going to Taiwanese
companies to bring them here which I'm
not sure the you know the percentages
but I know some of it at Le because the
reason the big reason why we have you
know companies that are doing things
overseas and stuff is because of labor
laws and because of regulations here so
if you environmental regulations yeah
the if you can p roll those back then
you could get then there's an incentive
for companies to start but as long as
the federal government government has
the the type of legislation that or
regulation that that disincentivizes
companies from starting I mean it's got
to start it somehow and I I I want I
want to correct you one thing not really
correct but I want to counter um I want
a strong robust American Empire that is
achieved by being really cool producing
great products being a great trade
partner not interfering in other
country's business and politics but
being so good at everything we do that
they want to learn from us we want we
want other countries to say let us know
what you that new thing you guys are
working on your econom is really great
we all love America we want to be like
America your movies are awesome we want
to win through cultural means yes not
bombing children yeah culture and
science those are my two favorites we
the US Empire uses force in a lot of
different ways you know if countries
like elect a government that the US
doesn't like they start putting economic
sanctions on them you know purposely to
destroy their economy yes yes but let's
be fair the US also removes that
government by force and then puts in a
sock puppet government sometimes
sometimes but other times they just
sanction the hell out of them and you
know that's that's part of the reason
why you know the US on the global stage
right now if you're like a developing
country and you see the way the US
operates especially now all for the past
year and a half you had blink Biden
talking about you know lecturing Russia
on the war in Ukraine talking about this
rules-based order and now we see them
fully backing Israel as they're just
blowing up kids and everybody can see it
for themselves it's like the hypocrisy
is is very obvious to other countries
but the the the funny thing about Russia
and Ukraine is Russia is having a
territorial territorial dispute with a
neighboring country mhm the United
States flew to the other side of the
planet to invade Iraq and Afghanistan
it's true and why was Iraq invaded well
I guess it was wmds but 911 was kind of
the pretext why was Afghanistan invaded
well because the Taliban were were
harboring Osama Bin Laden so we we got
to go and build a nation there and then
Russia invades a neighboring country
over a border dispute we're like whoa
whoa hey there wait a minute a right
like a few days after sorry if I got a
little worked up there Ian you looked a
little startled I'm so into this cona
rice a few days after Russia invaded was
on TV and was like I forget exactly what
she said but condalisa rice of the
George W Bush Administration said a
country cannot invade another Sovereign
Nation or something like that and did
you see do you remember George W Bush's
little uh Freudian slip or whatever it
was he was giving a speech and he was
like one man's decision to invade uh
Iraq uh uh
Ukraine and then he kind of left and he
was like yeah Iraq too that was a moment
man I watched that video like a 100
times this country is full of
definitely somewhere in his brain but
the founding fathers I think if they saw
what was going on they'd be like they'd
be stacking bodies' be why where are
your businessman in politics it's like
your grandfather being like son I gifted
you this really nice car and you toted
it you know what I mean yeah no the
found I want to stress this point too
the founding fathers notoriously just
petitioned over and over again and it I
I I think it's fair to say it was not
the Americans who started the
Revolutionary War it was the British
imposing tyranny like if we go straight
to Le and conquered they said hand over
your guns or else the Americans the
founding fathers were like I'm going to
write a strongly worded letter to the
king and the King's like screw off I'll
write another letter to the king and it
was a year and a month after uh uh Le
waston and Conquer they signed the
Declaration of Independence so it's not
like the Americans were like it's time
to stack bodies they were like Please
Please We're just trying to have some
representation here fair enough but you
know Washington did cross the Delaware
and kill everybody in their sleep so but
what but but that's in the war my point
is was later on WE America may be Rebels
but when we started we were not the
dudes who decided to go and kill other
people we were the dudes who who
honorably and reasonably said listen
listen what you're doing is not working
and we are telling you now this has to
change and if you don't listen to us the
change will come either way and then it
was the crown that was like we're going
to come and put you down and then we
said we didn't start it you did they
came to they came to Li and Concord and
they said we are going to come at you it
was not Americans who went to England to
to to fight it was the crown sending
regulars to to the Colony saying we are
going to impose our will from overseas
on you and brought the guns and then
demanded of of the Americans I think
that the the the the the founders of
this country were calm rational
reasonable people who understood war was
bad they did not want foreign
entanglements I love reading about the
the barbery wars and Thomas Jefferson
and like he's like we don't want to be
involved in any of this stuff why are
you attacking us what are the barber
Wars this is cool Pirates North Africa
and Jefferson and other founding fathers
Adams they're all basically just saying
like look man we're just selling stuff
we have no problem with any of you why
don't you leave us alone and they like
screw you we do what we want they said
to the it was they said to the to the in
England they said to the the United
States Representative they said the
Quran gives us the the approval and
authorization to kill you and take your
stuff because you are infidels and so
Thomas Jefferson created the United
States Marine Corps and that was the the
response was send in the Marines so the
Marines have been fighting for the
country for as long as there has been a
country this is the barber War series of
two wars fought by the United States
Sweden in the kingd of Sicily against
the barbar states Tunis alers and
Tripoli yeah and you made a point the uh
I oh sorry the the the United States
Marine Corps the Marine Corps hymn
there's the line that says uh to the
shores of Tripoli y that's what it's
referencing from the halls of montazuma
to the shores of trip Tripoli the Marine
Corps fought for the United States
that's a good song it's all right I like
it I remember you made the point before
we started recording that like you favor
you know the us could have a strong Navy
and kind of police the waters and work
with their trading partners to counter
piracy and I think that is a completely
legitimate uh you know foreign policy to
have just to have a navy and fight
piracy with your trading partners but
we're just so far from that we're in you
know meddling in every country around
the world you know we're not anything
close to that a lot of people like to
point to the barbery wars as an example
of how all the founding fathers actually
were not you know non-interventionists
but they were responding to their
property you know being attacked so it's
completely different Americans yeah um
yeah and so this is completely different
analogy from what you talking about
about how the British brought the war
here my my point was the founding
father's attitude was like hey let's
just mind our own business we're going
to do our thing here you leave us alone
and now the mentality of the United
States is we offer nothing but we take
yeah so what I what I imagine the United
States is doing with the with the
current Empire it's it's like a a piece
of bubblegum it's being blown up and
blown blown up and blown up but we know
what happens eventually it gets thinner
and thinner and thinner and then it pops
there is nothing within this bubble it
is hollow the United States cannot exist
by simply going out with guns and saying
we get to do this we can invade Iraq and
Afghanistan but Russia better not invade
anybody else to be fair Russia shouldn't
invade Ukraine M but the US has no leg
to no moral leg to stand on what the US
should do the US should have some type
of whatever you want to call it Empire
in the sense that we are so good our
laws are just our people are fat and
happy I mean that figuratively our
economy is great and it's done through
production it's done through trade it's
done through technological development
and then what happens nobody's people
people will be jealous because we're
rich that always happens but we're not
blowing up kids we're not aoral
crackpots our money isn't being siphoned
away from us our economy is expanding
our families are happy our kids are
happy our roads are taken care of our
infrastructure is taken care of and
other countries are like we need to be
like them look well they're doing you
want to spread democracy or whatever it
is you call it that's how you do it you
show up in a country with guns and then
kill the elderly and then try to raise a
new generation and you get Afghanistan
doesn't work mhm I love it I think that
the United States China and Russia have
a duty to protect the planet especially
the Arctic it it's so important we we're
right on the brink one thing back to the
British like bringing the war to America
you know when we talk about Ukraine I
mean for so long Putin and the Russians
were telling you know the us like you
know stop doing what you're doing stop
it and you know in the weeks and months
leading up to the invasion you know
almost a year before they were you know
massing troops and they they uh
submitted these security proposals they
wanted NATO to be rolled back they
wanted a guarantee that Ukraine would
never join NATO and the US just said no
basically to their main demand of
Ukraine joining NATO a state department
official admitted this in an interview
shortly after the Russian invasion and
so you know and I'm not you know
justifying Russia's Invasion but it is
very clear how the US and the West
provoked this thing and you know that's
the thing that's on Russia's border
we're you know we can't even we try to
put our self in the other person's shoes
could you imagine if Russia was funding
a war in Canada you know like there was
a civil war there and then we intervened
and Russia started sending them missiles
and intelligence there was just a report
in the Washington Post that said the CIA
in 2015 started building up Ukraine's
intelligence services the sbu and the g
which is their their Military
Intelligence to the tune of tens of
millions of dollars and uh they were
basically saying that because of that
support Ukraine's able to kill people
inside Russia they pointed to the car
bombing of Daria dugina do you guys know
who she is the daughter of Al Alexander
Dugan that the Ukrainian Fu did they
basically pointed to that saying they
were a they're able to do this remember
the CIA and the statue that exploded do
we know what that was about you remember
that there was a internet personality in
Russia someone brought in a small bus of
his
headed yeah that's that was them too
that that that report said it was them
and you know it it closed with a very
ominous quote from like a former CIA
official basically saying like what have
we created here what if they start
killing people in third countries you
know what if you know like the blowback
from this Ukraine war could be very
serious it's going to be like
Afghanistan it is it is going to be uh
uh like like the mujahadin it it is
Ukraine is now uh uh what was it the
Republicans pass a funding bill for
Israel but not Ukraine they're saying
it's going to be dead in the Senate Joe
Biden here let me pull the story up post
millennial Biden admin announces
additional $425 million military package
to Ukraine so we have weaponized and
armed Ukraine but Ukraine is losing the
appetite for funding this is on the
decline and we've got an election coming
up MH what do you think happens to
the extreme I'm not saying extremist I'm
saying like very fervent National
militia groups in Ukraine who are funded
and trained by US forces when the US
pulls out and says you're on your own
mhm you talk about the fear of bombings
in third countries other non you know
outside of Russia and stuff 100% And
then what happens give it 20 years and
you've got trained armed groups in
Ukraine who hate the United States for
some reason or another and you get
Al-Qaeda all over again yeah in some
form or another there's you know cuz you
you hear the Russians talk about the
Nazis in Ukraine but there is a real
Neo-Nazi element in Ukraine um you know
it's not huge but it is very influential
and there are certain groups so there
was like these raids going on in Russia
that were done by this group called The
Russian volunteer Corps they were
Russians Russian people that were
fighting you know went over to Ukraine
in 2014 to fight for them and they're
like openly Neo-Nazi wow and they had
American armored vehicles so you had a
group of neo-nazis basically invading
Russia and I think this was belgrad they
they tried this a few times they didn't
get much done but you have a group a
band of Nazis invading Russia with
American weapons like again fathom try
to put
yourself you know we can't even imagine
something like that happening to the the
Russians thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
800m and become a member over at Tim
cast.com for uncensored membersonly
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time